[Aplausos]
cuando empecé a terapia intentamos
llegar a la raíz de mi ansiedad y
resultó que tengo un trastorno de
ansiedad generalizada entonces no hay
una raíz hay muchas y sin embargo si
logramos dar con una y esa es hablar en
público entonces aquí estoy venciendo
mis miedos
y psicóloga me dijo que algo que me
podía ayudar muchísimo para ser muñones
de contarles cómo me siento entonces hay
les berlín hola soy pamela moreno tengo
22 años soy actriz y crear contenido y
me estoy muriendo de miedo tengo miedo
de que se me olvide
tengo miedo de tropezar y caer me tengo
miedo de que la calle literal pero
también tengo mucho nivel que me vaya
bien porque ansiedad ok ahora que me
liberé un poquito de esto les que hablar
del prejuicio que sobre la salud mental
vieron como yo llegué y les empecé a
platicar acerca de mí
y terapias como si les hubiera
practicado literal lo que comí ayer ok
afortunadamente para mi generación ya no
hay tanto prejuicios sobre la salud
mental énfasis de ventana sin embargo
para mis papás ens abuelos mis tíos
todavía de si vale controversial que
hablar de la política y del sexo
combinados cuando yo empecé a tener
trastornos de ansiedad y todo esto me
acuerdo perfecto que fue porque yo desde
muy chiquita ha sabido lo que quiero
hacer con mi vida sé que quiero actuar
quiero entretener a la gente y cuando
pamela era muy chiquita ella pensaba que
la manera que iba a lograr esto era
siendo súper extrovertida y grande
porque habían cámaras por todos lados
que nos estaban viendo todo el tiempo
como si fuera 1984 de george orwell pero
afortunadamente un par de años después
nos buscaron a mí ya mis hermanas para
hacer castings y comerciales y marco
perfecto y una vez estaba haciendo fotos
para trajes de baño y el fotógrafo me
dijo oye pamela deberías dejar de comer
porque ya te estás teniendo pancita
yo me voy así y tenía 10 años en ese
momento empecé a tener miedos de la
comida y hasta la fecha de tenido
anorexia bulimia orton xxi todavía no
sigo luchando pero gramos y de hecho
deje de hacer castings y comerciales
cuando tenía como 12 13 años porque me
daba miedo
el bullying y los a la autoestima porque
imagínense a pamelita de 12 entrando la
pubertad con un baby face que la acb era
de 10 años parada en casting al lado de
una brasileña guapísima de un 80 que es
y puso dos colitas una minifalda y tiene
25 pero dijo que tenía 14 mi autoestima
se fue al subsuelo y a eso le agregan
que los bullies porque ya saben cómo son
los niños chiquitos con te molestan y de
por sí genera la rara de mi escuela
entonces ya era el mundo juntos con
pamela porque hay no es la rara y ahora
se cambió a nuestros frutos con pamela
porque qué pena sale en revistas en
traje de baño o salen del hecho error
entonces deje de hacer comercial
decide que todo esto a pesar de que eran
mis sueños para poder encajar dentro de
la idea de lo que ellos quería que yo
fuera y dejar de tener miedo a que no
tuviera amigos a que no me aceptaran y
entonces poco a poco fui cambiando mi
esquema de lo que yo pensé que era hasta
que en prepa me sacaron del grupito de
amigos por mi décima vez y me quedé sola
porque no tenía amigos ya no me tenía ni
a mí misma porque me ha cambiado tanto
que ni siquiera sabía lo que quería
pensé que quería estudiar derecho y ser
diputado en algún momento que está bien
pero no es yo
y en ese momento empezó la depresión y
el problema con la depresión no es que
no sientas tristeza es que no sientes
nada y hay un hoyo en tu existencia haya
un vacío porque todo lo que te llamaba
la atención y te apasiona vaya me
interesa y ya como que no te dan ganas
de despertar del siguiente día para
volver a sentir nada y que nadie te
llame la atención y poco después empezó
a la ansiedad y curiosamente con la
ansiedad sientes todo me gusta pensar
que la ansiedad es como energía
acumulada imagínense cuando tomas café y
está súper acelerador ok ahora agrega le
estás cada días agrega le que empieza a
temblar como ahorita agrega le que está
súper paranoico todo se te nubla yo
decía que realiza en el país de las
maravillas' porque las cosas se me hacen
grandes y chiquitas y entonces pasé de
no sentir nada a no sentirlo todo y así
estuve como un año y medio y me daba
miedo decir la misma manera la pena de
que pensar que estuviera loca porque ni
siquiera yo soy un está entonces me lo
mantuve hasta que un día en el interno
que dios bendiga en internet encontré lo
que era la depresión y lloré porque
pensé que está sola y pensé que era algo
solo a mí me pasaba entonces llegué con
todo mejor ag decirle a mi mamá mamá
tengo depresión y mi mamá me dijo a mi
hijita si tú tienes depresión imagínate
yo no la pongo o sea haciendo pasa a
todos entonces me lo mantuve por otros
dos años hasta que mis ataques de pánico
surgieron cada dos tres veces al día ya
no podía existir sin miedo de salir de
mi casa entonces otra vez ahí fui y
decidí decirle a la psicóloga en mi
escuela y no está muriendo de miedo
porque pensé que esa psicólogas
fácilmente le podía decir a mis
compañeros que son los mismos que
provocaban esto dentro de mí y sin
embargo fui y le conté que no me siente
bien lo conté todo lo que me ha pasado y
le conté lo cerca que había estado a
terminar con mi vida
ella me refirió con una psicóloga de
energía con un psiquiatra y me dedicara
que es otro tema que es súper también
pero les puedo decir que sin el
medicamento yo no estaría yo aquí
ahorita y en el interno está medicada me
entró como el bichito de qué hubiera
pasado si me hubiera quedado haciendo
castings hice el casting para machos
frida y cuando mi mamá me marcó me dijo
que quede en lugar de estar súper
emocionada verificar por todos lados me
dio igual fue padre no para que padres
de de val y no poder disfrutar del
primer momento en el que en una película
y pues ya hicimos la película y yo me
veía así porque acababa de terminar de
tomar medicinas con hormonas para
regular mi periodo que es otro tema
extremadamente tabú y pues a mi
personaje le decían de papi
en lugar de estar yo súper orgullosa de
mí misma porque acaba de terminar mi
primera película tenía pavor de lo que
iban a decir los de mi escuela y los
demás de que saliera así y eso me
causaba una ansiedad brutal hasta el
nivel que en la premier me empecé a
sentir muy mal y ni siquiera me puedo
ver en la película hasta la fecha de
hecho
y ya y luego pasan unos años me primero
en américa y me marcan a decirme que
vamos a hacer la segunda película yo muy
emocionada porque ahora sí lo voy a
poder disfrutar y un mes y medio antes
de que empecemos rodaje me dicen que
tengo que subir 15 kilos si quiero
volver a hacer la película y en ese
momento se me cayó el mundo encima
porque se imaginarán que aparte de todos
mis trastornos yo sabía que se hacía
esos 15 kilos y subía de peso me iba a
fregar y tuve amigos que entendieron y
media no no lo hagas porque sabemos que
tu salud mental probablemente se acabe
pero también tiene mucha gente que no
entendía inician a importada o sea todos
los actores son el peso por personaje de
la talla de listerioris y sí pero para
mí en ese momento si yo lo hacía
y va a acabar con mi vida tuve que
escoger entre mi salud mental y mis
sueños y hasta la fecha estoy tan
agradecida de que puede ser que no me
costó muchísimo trabajo pero lo hice y
entonces en el año que me tomé para
poder hacer esa película que ya no hice
porque literal medio debajo un año dije
bueno pues vamos a compartir lo que yo
tengo que mis problemas de ansiedad y
depresión porque tal como yo me sentí
sola y yo pensé que era la única
probablemente haya más gente allá afuera
y empecé a hacer esto que tu vida se
convierta en la guía de supervivencia de
la imagen entonces empecé a subir que si
me tips o mis rutinas de ejercicio para
el energía acomodada que sentía se unió
y me empecé a dar cuenta lo
increíblemente malinformados y
maleducado es que estamos sobre la salud
mental me empezaron a llegar mensajes
que no puse
y me decían como gracias porque tu vídeo
me hizo entender que no estoy sola
gracias porque tu vídeo me dio a
entender que puedo seguir la vida más
allá y gracias a eso no matter o uno que
fue de gracias porque le enseñé a mi
vida tal cual a túnez a mi mamá y ya por
eso me van a llevar a ese color
está cañón
en méxico hay una mala información
brutal y en el mundo con la salud mental
y sin embargo también a través de redes
sociales encontrarán una comunidad
increíble de gente y he encontrado
oportunidades quien en la vida se me
hubieran ocurrido por ejemplo
aterrizamos soy imagen global de una
campaña de nike y quien se ve imaginado
que pasar de ser la peter a estar
en tiendas de making
quién sabe
necesitamos hablar de salud mental
porque una persona de cada diez en
méxico tiene depresión y piensa está
sola estamos hablar más de salud mental
porque 7 de cada 50 tienen ansiedad y
piensan que se van a morir diario y no
entienden por qué estamos hablar de
salud mental porque pasan hasta 14 años
entre que sale un síntoma y te pueden
llegar a diagnosticar ni siquiera
tratamiento estamos hablar más de salud
mental porque la mamá de mis mejores
amigas el papá
y yo conocía a este señor que hace más
de 10 años y era una persona nuevamente
feliz y nunca te hubieras imaginado que
detrás de esto tenía una bipolaridad mal
diagnosticada y depresión masiva
y entonces se preguntan qué padre pamela
pero que hago muy fácil vayan al
psicólogo y me van a decir benefician
estiman no tienen economista todos
necesitamos en el psicólogo
el psicólogo es para aprender a vivir
contigo y para tener a vivir con los
demás en paz
no pasa nada no tienes que estar loco
para ir al psicólogo que tenemos no sé
salir a dos todos hemos sentido unos
solos todos hemos estado en algún lugar
super oscuro en alguna vez en nuestras
vidas no lo hablamos necesitamos
reconocer esos sentimientos y platicarlo
porque no estamos solos nunca estamos
solos y probablemente hay alguien allá
afuera que sienta lo mismo que tus
indistria reconozcamos esos sentimientos
porque por algo están ahí y por último
ser la persona que necesitabas cuando
era más joven conviértete en aquello que
te hubiera ayudado y estuviera impulsado
y tal y como lo necesitabas gracias
[Aplausos]